hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Riga Fida grand prix 2019
we already checked out to classical
games so man we are one the first one
then Maxime equalized and then something
very interesting happened basically what
we are seeing now is the Armageddon but
here I have the well the the cross table
from chess 24 so as you can see the
first two games were decisive first one
by mamita of second one by max Eva
hologram with white then we have a
series of draws so all the rapid games
were drawn and then in the blade section
first Madera won a game with black as
you can see and then all he needed was a
draw basically with the white pieces and
then maxime beaugeois graphic an
equalized by winning with black in blitz
so this is game nine of their hold of
the final and it's an Armageddon so
Maxima sherrilyn graph has white in the
armageddon mommy taught of chose to be
black I don't know why he gets to choose
not really not really sure but he he
chose to be black which means that
Maxime gets five minutes on the clock
mama DRF gets four minutes on the clock
and Maxime has to win mommy Europe is
you know happy with a draw as whittled
rocky wins the match so here we have a
nice photo of the two of them meeting
before the game there we have a nice
handshake it's not this game I don't
have a photo of the Armageddon yet but
we do have this one so you can see it's
a bit of an awkward handshake Maxime
leaning forward a bit much you know
mommy they are of still didn't fully
reach the table and you can see the
water bottles are there on the table so
they are prepared to have a long day
ahead of them so without further ado
sorry about that
let's check out the game Maxime with the
white pieces opens with Knight to f3
we have Knight to f6 the red is on the
board g3 g6 and the both players
fianchetto their bishops on the Kings
side we have c4 castles by moment Europe
and now d4 and with the d6 we transpose
into the Kings Indian defense with
castles by Maxine and mount Knight B to
d7 nice to see three with E 5 now and
Queen to c2 we have a trade in the
center
pawn captures Knight captures and now
rook to e8 and here rook to d1 with a
six by black preparing Ruby 8 and B 5 B
3 and Maxime prepares the Finca to the
light square Bishop rook to b8 getting
the rook out of this well long diagonal
and now Bishop to b2 and Knight to e5
bye-bye mama D are off so what do you
play here here at Maxime so a very nice
idea and he played c5 it's not that mama
D I missed this this move has been
played before but it's maybe an
unpleasant move to meet well in in an
Armageddon game where D you know winning
of the Grand Prix depends on it so here
of course if you capture a knight c6
just wins the Queen the Queen has
nowhere to go the knight control these
seven square and you would have to give
up some pieces for the Queen for example
Knight captures rook captures Knight
captures and well you would get some
material back but it would not be enough
so after c5 with d5 by mama D off and
now comes h3 there are two games in the
database where efore was played sorry by
Maxime but Maxime plays h3 it is a new
move so already as I move 14 we have a
completely new game night back the
seasons by Mahmoud era of challenging
the knight on d4 where Knight captures
beat captures and now efore of course
you cannot capture due to the Queen
being on the same file as the rook
Bishop to e6 now defending the d5 pawn
with a double capture here and now Queen
to d2 putting pressure on the pawn here
but not really it's not like you're
gonna be able to capture it
Mahmud Europe doesn't even bother
defending and we have Queen to e7 now
capturing just loses the rook here you
don't really have a good way of replying
to this you could try and move your
queen somewhere to g5 but then just
Knight captures and your queen is under
attack if you first capture the Queen
denied captures back and well you've
just lost a piece so after Queen e7 we
have rook a to c1 by maxim and now rook
B to d8 again putting the rook on this
very nice file that the Queen occupies
with rook to e1 white does the same now
and Queen back to d7 attacking the h3
pawn so King to h2 defending it and now
h5 mummies are ready to push h4
and now Knight to e2 it would be great
if this night could get the d4 square
from d4 it would control c6 also
pressure the bishop here so you would
really enjoy pushing c6 here but first
the Bishop to f5 and now Knight the d4
can be met with Knight to e4 Black
Knight coming to e4 could also be a
problem for white so we have a cease
sorry
first C story after Bishop to a5 first
we have c6 by white attacking the Queen
and now comes Queen to b6 no idea I'm
constantly thinking how black should
play c6 and then I tried to play you
know two moves with black about okay
Queen to f4 now here maxime offers to
trade Queens and go into the same game
where he will have this well quite
advanced opponent ceases but it's not a
passed pawn whereas in Maumee tariff has
a past D pawn but okay Mammadov trades
with Queen captures Knight captures and
now d4 he already has a rogue behind a
passed pawn so of course he wants to
start pushing his passed pawn
maxime trades a pair of rooks we have
rook captures now sorry the rook has to
keep an eye on the d4 pawn here so
Knight captures and now rook to d1 just
defending against the pawn and now eight
four and here if you accept the pawn on
h4 it's not really you know I'm not
really a great pawn your pawns are
double here on the h-file black and play
rook see to just attack the rook and
after Luke the d2 Bishop e5 is really
strong so what you play here King to g3
now there should be one and it's just a
very ugly position to be in for white so
after this age four with Bishop to f1 by
maxime and now H captures on g3 we have
pawn captures Sanji three and now a five
as the pawn on a6 was a target so Bishop
to c4 now with some ideas well you are
pinning the F pawn here so maybe if you
put g4 if this Bishop moves away you can
play something like Knight captures on
g6
but it's very hard to imagine as always
Bishop to e5 will be will be a threat so
first Knight to d6 challenging the
bishop here brush up to d5 and now
Knights to b5 preparing to bring this
over 2 C 3 and here again like we said
g4 isn't good because well it's it's it
just Falls the Bishop to e5 it's pretty
bad and now if you capture here you get
Bishop captures with check King g2 and
rook captures on d5 the knight is no
longer here to guard the bishop
so here Maxime decides it's time to move
back the bishop the bishop to f3 and now
what do you play here
here were rook to d6 was played which is
uh you know a nice move but there was a
better one Bishop the c2 is super strong
here because after Luke to d2 then you
play d3 challenge the bishop on b2 and
after this trade you would have this
nice position where the rook is pretty
much helpless to stop anything here nice
- a 3 is coming followed by Knights to
be 1 you're just gonna kick away the
rook and then pusher pusher a deep on to
victory but you know this is Armageddon
both players are very very much looking
not to spend too much time on each move
so rook to d6 first and out rook to d2
not allowing Bishop to c2 to come with a
threat with Bishop to e5 now so not even
allowing g4 and now Knight to d3 with
Bishop captures on d3
now mama D are of parts with his bishop
pair we have rook captures and now
Knight to c3 and now this straight here
is possible for example Bishop captures
pawn captures rook captures Bishop
captures and there should be one
preventing want to see - yes you do have
an endgame 5 points each with bishops of
opposite color and you know Maxine can
draw this no problem but if he draws the
game then mama Yara wins the grand prix
so he cannot afford to play something
like this so we have a four he still has
to look for his chances and and try and
win this with Knights to d5 by Mahmoud
Arif and now Bishop to e3 challenging
the rook here the rook has to keep you
know an eye on the night here so rook to
b8 and now Bishop to c5 threatening to
win the pawn here but now Knights the e3
we have king - g1 the idea is night to
f1 check followed by Knight captures in
g3 so King to g1 stopping night to f1
track and now just f5 mama Jarvis is
very happy with his position he doesn't
even have to
sure anything he's just happy with the
draw so you know if Maxime does nothing
you know he's very happy with it and you
know it's already moved moved 39 and he
caught up with time Maxime is lower on
the clock as he so it's in pretty much
equal position he's the one who has to
keep looking for chances for some secret
win and you know time just keep the
clock keeps ticking away and also you
know it's definitely not a pleasant
position to be in
since this is more 39 that there is no
increment here or no delay but as of
most 60 players do get increments so
what Maxime really should try and do
survive until move 60 without you know
over committing to something and then
maybe you know shift his pieces around
while getting the increment and then
maybe trying to find some sort of a win
so pink to f2 and now King to f7 the
mama euro also starts bringing his King
into the game and now before my media
decides to create a story
maxime decides to create a passed pawn
here we have pawn captures Bishop
captures and now you do have the best a
pawn we've roped b8 Mamedov now wants to
get his rogue behind the passed pawn
which is something you always want to do
push up the e1 and now rook to be one
preparing rook to a one with a five and
the point is no nicely protected by the
bishop but still rook to a one not
allowing at this point to start marching
forward we've looked to b3 and now comes
a rook to a to check with Bishop to e2
and now Knight to d5 King to f3
unpinning and but now King to f6 and
here we have g4 challenging this pawn
here and mommy York doesn't mind with
phone captures H captures and now rook
to a1 attacking the bishop here and here
yes Bishop to d2 would be best here for
white as you do have to keep an eye on
this a 5-point here but Mac seen for a
long time he just played Bishop page
four check
mama you're blocked and now you can no
longer regain control of your precious
a5 passport so he played the show to
have to and now mama Daryl just captured
it he checked if there were any tricks
but there weren't any tricks
so just wrote captures on a5 now mommy
job is up upon and well Maxime still has
to try and win this game we have worked
be eight now rook to a3 check King t4
and now tonight's the c3 check with King
to d3 and here you could even go here
among your plate 95 with a discover
check whether you can also try a night
d1 check which picks up the bishop on f2
you don't really win a piece because
after King c4 captures you get a rook to
f8 check winning winning it back for
example rook captures on f2 and it's
still winning for black but you know you
don't want to over spend time trying to
look for for anything here but rooks III
checking before a now d3 will be very
strong after the bishop moves king king
d5 and so on but like I said you know
every second is precious so Knights to
d5 with check King to c4 and now Knight
the b6 with check we have King Tubby 5
and now d3 finally with Bishop to d1 and
now rook to a 1 just attacking the
bishop here and here
bishop characters and b6 was played a
much stronger was Bishop to f3 and then
after D - now you trade the shop
character C captures and rook to d8 you
prevent the pond from queening but still
this will yield nothing more than a draw
probably after let's say Ruby 1 check
you have to keep an eye on the b6 pawn
king a6 now Bishop good for guarding the
pawn and it's still 3 points to - yeah
like I said
maxime can grab a draw but he's not
getting anything with a draw so we have
Bishop captures and b6 c capture son b6
and now rook to f8 check King to e7 and
now rook to f1 defending the bishop here
but now King to d6 we have King back the
c4 hoping to win the pawn here key point
2 d2 and now came to d3 here Bishop to
f4 just guarding the pawn here with rook
to h1 by Maxime now rook to a3 check
King to e4 and here
Mahmud are played rooked III check and I
believe it was in this position that
Maxime or sherrilyn Grove
either resigned the game or he had no
more seconds left on his clock this is
most 64 so they were getting increments
for their previous 4 move so I don't
think he ran out of time but it is
possible you know
but there isn't all that much to do so
once once the King moves you're gonna go
rogue before then rookie one just forces
a win here you either have to capture
and then black gets Queen into the game
or if you try rook h6 check King c7
again your Bishop is under attack you
have to play something official to f3
then you just bring a queen into the
game and that's sufficient for a
winnable capture look we'll capture with
check you're gonna move and then well
you're just up a piece and in a
completely winning position yeah after
this rook to e3 check we don't know what
happened but Momiji our of won the the
feeder Grand Prix in Riga 2019 so even
though a mommy job got kicked out of the
previous Grand Prix by the the new dubov
I believe I'm pretty sure it was by
dubov and he didn't grab all that many
Grand Prix points here he again you know
comes up on top as the leader of the of
the feeder Grand Prix with with 10 full
points so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
after now finishing the the short
coverage of the feeding Grand Prix I
will return to a couple Blanca saga and
checking up on your suggestions I have
seen a couple of very interesting
suggestions so I'll probably cover those
before going into the Capablanca saga
again and we're just gonna see where we
go from there I would like to thank Paul
Woodhall Douglas bro hard caramel or
Latif Dungey and Yosef a valine
for a contributor to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as you
really can check to on my previous
videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content I think oh I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and don't forget to update
your agamotto chess clock season